okay today I'm going to talk to you
about speed so speed is essentially just
how fast an object is moving and it can
be summed up by this really really
simple equation triangle which shows
speed equals distance divided by time so
that's what each of these stand for S
stands for speed which is measured in
meters per second we have D which stands
for distance which is just measured in
meters and T is time which is measured
in seconds so the really kind of simple
way of writing this out is speed equals
distance divided by time so let's just
show you a real quick example of how to
find the speed of a moving object so
let's say I had a ramp like this and I
had a little toy car that went on that
ramp like this so in order to calculate
the speed I need to find the distance
and I need to find the time so the first
thing that I do is I'd measure the
distance that it was traveling down in
the ramp so let's say that distance for
the sake of argument was 2 meters so
that's the distance what I will then
have to do is it up to time how long it
takes for the for the car to get from
here to here so all I need is a stop
clock so here's my local stop clock and
our time how long it takes second it
starts moving I start a stop clock
second it finishes moving I stop the
Scott stop clock and that will tell me
the average speed of this little toy car
so let's say it was four seconds that
it's taken to travel that two meters to
find the speed I need to do distance
divided by time so I need to do 2
divided by 4 and that gives you my speed
which would be 0.5 meters per second so
the only other thing I'm going to show
you is a couple of examples of different
speeds just so I could try and
in context how fast a couple of things
uh so first of all someone walking
usually traveling an average speed of
around 1.4 meters per second so that
means every second they travel 1.4
meters now obviously different people
walk at different speeds but that is
kind of like an average one running
could get much faster it could be
anywhere from around three meters per
second and the fastest person in the
whole world ever recorded was Usain Bolt
who ran at ten meters per second but
that really really really is very fast a
car or rather a bad picture of a van
this traveling down the motorway would
be traveling at around 31 meters per
second and finally let's give you just
the speed of sound so the speed of sound
so sound traveling through the air
throws it around 340 meters per second
that means every second that sound
travels 340 meters so that's essentially
speed it's a nice this nice equation
triangle can you could use to find time
or distance as well and that is how to
you find the speed of a moving object
nice and simple thank you